دكتور مهاتير انت كنت من الداعمين دائما
للقضيه الفلسطينيه القضيه الفلسطينيه ضاعت
في اروقه الامم المتحده ام ضاعت بسبب
سياسات داخليه ام ماذا
ما هو المخرج
فلسطين
لم يربح الفلسطينيون قضيتهم بسبب دعم
الولايات المتحده لاسرائيل فالولايات
المتحده دوله قويه جدا ولذلك يمكن
لاسرائيل ان تقوم باي شيء بما في ذلك خرق
القانون الدولي وامريكا تدعمها وتدافع
عنها في مجلس الامن وعسكريه لذلك وبهذا
الوضع لا يمكن حل القضيه الفلسطينيه حلها
لا يمكن ان يتم الا في حال خضوع الجميع
للقانون وفي حال التوقف دعم واشنطن
لاسرائيل والذي نراه يتكرر حتى في حال خلق
اسرائيل للقانون
هل ترى انه في في امل بمفاوضات بين
الجانبين الاسرائيلي الفلسطيني ممكن ان
تصل الى حل
اعتقد ان الحل هو في اجتماع الطرفين فقط
للفلسطيني والاسرائيلي على مائده الحوار
من دون ان يتقاتل هذا هو الاسلوب الامثل